this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and today
he's getting all nostalgic looking at
the weapons of valve's iconic shooter
franchise
counter-strike
wow the ultimate tribute getting sprayed
on the wall in a counter-strike game
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
just like this and if you'd like to help
out the royal armies museum and continue
to support jonathan's work check out the
links in the description of this video
right over to jonathan
paul's there ah the deagle nature's
beautiful deagle correct me if i'm wrong
comment section
but i'm pretty sure that's where the
contraction deagle originated
i have got one here so this is of course
absolutely iconic
by the time counter-strike was conceived
of as
uh the ultimate action movie handgun
counter-strike did quite a good job for
the time the original graphics at
representing that all the angles on it
are a little bit rounded off i don't
know if they're showing off how many
polygons they had but um the desert
eagle the real one
is famously extremely angular and for me
the model in the game is quite
rounded there's also a symptom of
something that i think we'll see
certainly throughout all the original
counter-strike guns which is that
as soon as you hit reload the slide
magically locks itself open
of course there's no reason why that
would happen and that's just a shortcut
in the reload animation where it's
cutting straight
to the slide lock reload as we would
call it
you know i remember i played a lot of
counter-strike
beta back in the day probably one of the
few games where i did use the desert
eagle by choice
this this is um like some sort of
reminiscence therapy for me it's that
long ago that i've played counter-strike
uh so the the arctic warfare the
accuracy international
bolt action sniper rifle i think this is
meant to be the
the magnum so 300 win mag or 338 don't
know the glaring thing here
which we'll see with other a lot of
other models i'm sure is the left-handed
arrangement now a very helpful
viewer contacted me after a previous
video that we did on bad company 2
where i commented on the left-hand
ejection of the guns in that game and
how that used to annoy me i had
completely forgotten that in well all
versions of counter-strike
the guns are if you have them
right-handed they're mirrored and i
wasn't even aware that this was the
issue i just thought oh for some reason
they've
modeled everything on the left-hand side
it must be so you can see the cartridge
case is flying
and well i'm not so sure about that
theory now because it turns out the
developer
the original developer of counter-strike
was left-handed and modeled
everything in the game to be shown
left-handed and therefore
with the ejection port and the hand bolt
handle and all of that on the right hand
side where it should be
but because most players are
right-handed the game would be set up
with the gun modeled on the right side
but to do that
they had to flip the image so you end up
with
all your guns the wrong way round yeah
so a fascinating bit of video game
history there so
thank you yan for for messaging me about
that
so we've got the the stairman liquor tmp
i'm not sure the suppressor's modeled
very well it's a bit a bit
small and seems sort of stuck on the end
the real tnp has this very large
barrel jacket which is then threaded on
the outside for a suppressor it's not a
bad model
for the era i suppose it's a little bit
blocky of course the rate of fire seems
about right
the really weird thing of course is the
uh the report
this thing sounds like some sort of ray
gun
it really it is almost literally going
pew pew pew
um i've not been paying attention but i
think our capacities are a little bit
off
i know from having played a lot of the
early game and
one of the his some of the history i've
read that this was a classic for game
balancing
so if you see um like an 18 round
capacity where it should be 20
or even less it's because they started
out with a full
mag and they've just removed rounds to
make it have the reload animation kick
in
sooner and balance what would otherwise
be an overpowered
gun
so i'm not sure i remember or didn't
remember this being in the game until i
saw the gameplay clip and it all uh
some of it at least flooded back to me
and so i've looked at this
many times over the years in our
collection and not made the connection
that this was a counter-strike gun so
that's quite nice it's a 22-inch
barrel so relatively short for a
long-range rifle and that's because this
was a
concept it's a bit debatable today as to
whether this still has a niche but these
are still made as far as i know and
there are one or two others out there
an unusual looking rifle which is
probably why it was
white was selected for the game we're
looking at a 10 round capacity
in the game well this mag's five rounds
but there is a 10 round extended mag
available
and i think the game model does depict
that with all of about three polygons
something that the game
cannot depict is
the funky built-in bipod so that the
front bit of the handguard
pivots down to give you a quick deploy
bipod that doesn't get in the way
doesn't add any extra weight a really
neat idea and of course like so many
counter-strike game
guns it is in fact uh mirrored the wrong
way round
i'll try not to harp on that too much
because we know the reasons why now
now this this pistol i do fondly
remember from og counter-strike days i
didn't think i ever played source um
which i think is the version we're
watching here but a lot of stuff carried
over including
the 92s 92 g's i think they are in the
game
now the dual wield thing of course that
needs to be needs to be dealt with
it's not something that i think you
would ever do
unless i don't know some sort of
emergency situation where you're on your
own in a very in very tight quarters and
you happen to have two
two pistols and you've got one chance to
put as much fire as you can
on the enemy you might fire away with
two two pistols
so it can be done and um if you are
somewhat ambidextrous
well if you're not you can't do it but
if you are you have a chance
so now my my preference in in gaming
generally
is i'll i'll try a bit of a bit of dual
wheel just for the fun of it
but i'll typically revert to just using
one at a time
[Laughter]
oh dear paul's there well the ultimate
tribute
getting sprayed on the wall in a
counter-strike game the depictions of
the ump
this one included maybe i'm reading into
it but it looks like there's a
like there are bright marks on the side
of the receiver
like the receivers made of some sort of
metal now the ump
is extremely lightweight relies a great
deal on glass reinforced polymer just
like a
block frame but it's throughout the gun
with these relatively early
graphics i don't think we ever really
get the sense of it being
a different material than the other guns
maybe it's more of a limitation in
graphics than a mistake but that's just
my impression
gameplay terms a harder hitting slower
firing submachine gun offers a bit of
variety so it does fit
right we're in we're past we're well
past my era of counter
now although i did download and try
counter-strike go i was surprised to see
the the negev make an appearance
because if you get a light machine gun
of that nature 556 light machine gun in
a game is usually the minimum it seems
it's a bit bit too portable but then
that's that's fair to say of all machine
guns in first person shooters is that
they
they seem to be a bit too much like
assault rifles i think we've covered
that before on the series having said
that though it is relatively light for
for a 556 machine gun but what we see is
the players having to switch to his
knife constantly
so that he's not encumbered by the
machine gun i don't need to tell anyone
at home
that's not how life works so you'd have
to of course
throw the machine gun away or hand it to
an assistant or something i don't know
and then run around with your knife and
then get hold of another gun somewhere
you're
gaming the system of course by doing
that because it's almost like in
a first person shooter if the weapon's
not equipped it's not on you if you take
a step back from from
your gaming head and just watch people
running around it does strike you as a
bit odd that oh suddenly he's running
faster but he's still carrying the same
weight
another sort of early 2000s favorite uh
the fn p90 so this version is depicted
with
iron sights on the on the rail now the
versions we've got
have a sight through set of iron sights
built into that rail so you can either
put a an optical sight on top of the
rail or you just peer through the block
of metal that is the
the site i very much doubt these the
developers the modelers had
access to a real p90 to check that quite
possibly didn't even care
not something you'd see from reference
images so most in-game
guns even today are modeled from
reference images
right away though my eyes locked
straight onto that iconic magazine on
top of the gun
and at first i thought oh it's some
weird opaque magazine that doesn't show
the rounds but it does show
those transverse rounds which which as
you i'm sure you know
move to the rear and there's a very
clever rotary follower in the mag that
rotates them
and then pushes them into the weapon we
don't see any of that action happening
it's a solid or rather it's a flat
texture that doesn't do anything dealing
here with a relatively basic game by
modern standards
and it's not alone in older games in
depicting the p90 without showing you
the rounds moving and as far as models
go it does
it looks fine when it's static but when
it's firing nothing's moving
things have moved on by this point so
we're we're in we're still in um
cat strike global offensive the weapons
are modeled much more accurately
um with a lot more detail we're no
longer ejecting to the wrong side of the
weapon
and we've got some updated stuff from
later in the 2000s and one of those bits
of kit is
the fn scar and the mark 20
is kind of as i say on the top end of a
dmr bottom end of the sniper rifle
and it looks cool it embraces that
desert tan
aesthetic that modern firearms have
adopted partly in recognition or in
large part
in recognition of the fact that black is
actually not a great colour for a
firearm
it tends to stick out quite a lot
against camouflage clothing against the
environment
solid black is not what you want which
is
why from at least the second world war
onwards people were
camping up their weapons so it tells us
a little bit about the era that this
version of the game was
produced in and it's not a bad depiction
for
you know this is not milsim this is a
competitive first person shooter
and my first thought there is that was a
hell of a long-range shot
a for a video game shotgun because
they're notoriously short-ranged with a
massive amount of scatter
and b that's a hell of a shot for a
weapon with no stock
with a very short barrel so it's kind of
um like from it from a from the sort of
real world perspective
you would struggle to achieve that and
from the even from the video game
perspective
you wouldn't expect to be able to
achieve that so that one took me by
surprise
it's the the mag 7 which is just a a
really
wacky pistol shotgun effectively from
south africa
and the thing about these sort of south
african funnies
as you might call them is an absolute
ingenious design that's gone into a lot
of them but a lot of them
are of questionable utility outside of
i suspect what most of them are designed
for which is defensive
of property so lots of firepower at
close range you hopefully won't need it
but if you do
there's a lot of firepower on hand so
they don't really lend themselves to
military or even police adoption and
this one certainly didn't
oh this is like some sort of haunting
some sort of ghost from my past i
remember as a student
lurking the forums for for
counter-strike and seeing
a new animation for the m4 and the
player character yanks on the forward
assist
to chamber around and instantly i was on
there with a comment saying that's not
correct
and i had convinced myself that they had
fixed that but in whatever version of
the original game this is they haven't
wow i didn't think i'd see that again so
to be clear
it's the the the bit at the back that
looks like a bar
behind the carrying handle is what
you're supposed to pull on
to [ __ ] an ar-15 m16 m4
why am i talking about it well i can
show you so the way the gun's supposed
to work now bearing in mind
everything's on the wrong side because
we're back to left-handed but flipped
and you're supposed to pull on this to
cox the weapon
what you're not supposed to do is pull
on this
because it doesn't do anything what this
is is a forward assist
which assists the bolt forward that's
why it's called that
right we've moved we've advanced into
the source engine and
the m4 is looking better but we've
carried over another quirk from the
original game
i don't really know where this has come
from this is
the dust cover it covers the gun from
dust or the bolt
and whenever you [ __ ] the rifle it
springs open what counter-strike does
for no reason at all is flap this thing
open and shut
now it's possible that they have seen a
machine gun i can't think of a type that
does
this but they do exist where there is a
dust cover that sort of opens and shuts
but it's more just loose and is flapping
in the breeze kind of thing this is
sprung it's held flat against the side
doesn't appreciably move when you shoot
the weapon so that's a weird one it's
not a bad depiction
of an m4 apart from those annoying
technical details
right another slight frustration um
we've moved on we've got the
bolt release being used to chamber
around after a reload unfortunately
that's done
regardless of when you reload so if you
were to fire half a magazine
replace it with a fresh magazine you
just have to pull the trigger
you don't need to do anything else i
tend to think in errors we're an era
where
developers of a game like this aren't
putting in quite the same
attention to detail for i guess fans of
military hardware it's to do with
how much you value gameplay versus how
much you value technical detail
and just like in the movies it's just
slide slide your scale where you like
because you won't have time to do both
of those to the best you of your ability
i don't not without years and yeah i
guess
potentially money does come in as well
that's a really interesting bit of
evolution there first
the original counter-strike model very
low poly no
no real moving parts here's one i
prepared earlier so we're
talking of course about the kalashnikov
assault rifle the dust cover
selector here on that model is literally
just a flat
part of the texture of that bit of the
receiver way lower detail
and it's the earlier machined
receiver ak just the plain old ak often
called the ak-47
in contrast to that super simple early
model the
uh source version although it's still on
the wrong side
we now have that moving safety selector
the bolt is coming back and forth and
there's way so much more detail that the
cocking handle looks the right shape the
contour of the bolt is there the first
model had this weird like
square cocking handle like they just
slapped some a couple of polygons on
there and forgot to change their shape
not knocking it it's a very early and
kind of grassroots
developed game so that's not a criticism
it's just a reflection of the period it
was made in
so as as is usually the case the
capabilities of the weapon aren't badly
done so that the rate of fire is about
right
the sound is okay for the period i'm
noticing
some fairly pronounced recoil um
obviously with the
the crosshairs that diverge to indicate
likely dispersion and then you get
muzzle climb
that's pretty fair this is a an amazing
piece of industrial design among other
things
but the considerable mass of the bolt
carrier and the big long piston that
lives in here
and the to some extent the recoil energy
just of the cartridge which is higher
than something like 5.56
all contribute to quite a bit of muzzle
rise and quite a bit of felt recoil it's
not
a lot of recoil but you know you've
fired it more so than something like an
ar-15
so they're doing their best to reflect
that i think
finally we've got the last of the three
eras of counter-strike if you like so
what 2012
we've moved on to the akm
uh specifically the akm n because it has
the
side rail for um i think it's
coincidence but um the n stands for
knight
as in night sights so that's a
legitimate variance if anyone's looking
at that and thinking what's that gubbins
on the left-hand side
that's legit and of course the graphics
have come on massively since the
previous games
way more detail way more fidelity as to
the real world
gone it sort of handles and moves around
on the screen more convincingly it's
kind of
a bit intangible but um it just looks
you know it's they've tried to keep pace
with developments in modern
shooters and um don't have done a good
job for the
even that is quite a few years ago now
please do come and visit us if you're in
the uk or in the future if you're able
to visit the uk
at um our leeds museum the royal
armouries museum we've got fort nelson
down on the south coast
and the tower of london as well we've
got links in the description as ever if
you'd
like to kindly donate but otherwise
we'll see you again next time
[Music]
you